this is a production of cornell
university
so you create my my great italian return
to my uh the home department to report
my homework to our teachers i saw
several professors here and probably
manny online
and have you know also think about the
gun for very nice surveillance
and it's kind of encouraging
so i would like to take the ability to
share some fake one here and then this
is person's life
when i was blessed over here my positive
baby parrot
university
and another one was born in the corner
of medical school in new york
so this is a picture we removed the
customer of the texas a m's uh
so now
and i returned two kids to the school to
in my school as well
and
uh you know they're a student in texas
university in uh
engineers work and here's my wife
actually my wife
so it's pretty much the brief history
after i graduate from here from
and
after you know graduation work here i
began to move for field by lifetime this
one is
uh incumbent stage because
people find out this very new exciting
things and also have a great potential
to use the application for
agriculture and also pharmaceutical
fields recorded you know small and in my
name so i established my identity and
studying project from a
so today i would like to take this
opportunity to share
one of the projects one direction from
my lab and in this
introduction
so we know from high school in high
school you know the genetic
science scientology is that
genetic information restore the dna with
the transplant rna finally made in the
protein
and now it turned out after the after
sequence that came up people realized
that
and for human human eighty percent of
eighty percent of the enemy you know
they can transplant like rna however
among the champions
among hundreds only one point five
percent
is messenger army and then
nature produces such amount high amount
our non-coding army that must have good
reasons right so turns out with your
accumulated knowledge people have been
assigned that thinking
this non-calling army have been involved
pretty much every biological processes
but molecular level in involving
transcription isolation splicing or
cellular trafficking algebra trans
kindle engine and
traffic
and also using using the basement people
find out also involve the nucleus
nuclear complex space separation
so one group you know of course so many
things here sooner broad build and my
lab focus well on it
migrating so only when you support china
one could transform new clients even
despite very small size it turns out
this microwave have a giant huge
partnership in biological presence and
also well abundant for units for humans
we have like a 30-southern genes a
similar number with arbitraries as
plants it turned out more than sixty
percent more than half when sixty
percent of the transcripts was graduated
by my name and each microneed also
contains multiple multiple uh countries
so for instance
until 2018 have you find almost two
thousand micron in human and you can see
and each transcripts were targeted by
multiple micrometers meanwhile single
micronic regions 128 will target that
many times which highlight producing
that
genes that control all these kind of
biological processes so it turned out
for the new solution my planning and
passenger annex
into windows
circular
network make biological so
communicating
so for advances we have like super have
been reporting more than 376
micron
and the other parts you can see rise in
the wings and surviving reported more
than several hundreds okay another one
also
this kind of micron is also involved
with many important agriculture traits
for instance actually for rice okay they
have been involved in the flower
development timing global development i
mean surviving and
also involved in managed us and other
stresses so understanding this migraine
in biology process is really critical
for us to
not only understand biology but also
fully use this one engineering uniquely
processes better
and also for pharmaceutical purposes
for judge questions after now in the
animal field okay so we all know we'll
get the capital that's the capital
problem we know there's a messenger
under the magazine so cannot use our
name as a drug in substitute for
molecules have been punished and it
becomes very problematic for use one
common called iron land they have been
launched more than 40 40 more than 40 at
this moment
so morning for mike and the business but
they delivered this one premium label to
cure all these diseases for instance
2018 they announced the first
partisan policy israel first our
nigerian department for the new policy
and the second one will release the 2019
the treatment is targeted high paprika
for per year
so
there'll be more and more this kind of
drug have been used to trigger human
disease
but plants we also we can use new
technology okay for instance we can
engineering these plants and lasers
within certain certain virus physical
viruses
into
micronic contract and then make
transgenders tangents so nowadays
transgender intensive resistance then
tolerance for the virus infection and
also people have been using since my
name from hybrid
against treatment and
not only this how to have a treatment
insect and miserable have been widely
used okay so in other words home message
is that this one is
rna-based drug and
becomes
very increasingly important for
agriculture and by technology
so my lab of course we want to study
with applications and knowledge most
important things we need to understand
fundamental measurements for example
work at the believing level and by
chemical level so our lab one of
direction is used on the outputs at the
motor origins so that how exactly the
micron was produced and how it's
actually loaded into the parliament okay
finally use the cells and complex to
function
so for instance okay briefly using this
carbon we showed that microneed would be
transcribed by iron polymerase ii they
form this whole structure is how this
structure will be recognized by big
bible nuclear protein complex called the
microprocessor
these microprocessors have been keeping
though
constituted with three major protein
diesel with enzymes tara1 is defined by
embodying another body for consuming
with the main problem today so for this
part we know where once a failed form is
holding structure after the sequential
process eventually making 21 to 24
nucleotides to minimize from here one of
one of the strengths we have loaded
mature in protein called arthropods
formed activated on an induced saline
complex this risk complex and also
called discoveries were trafficked from
nuclear
for
ela cleavage complementary messenger
upload the protein translation so this
is pretty much
super we know is
basically biochemical vaccines for
micronutrients in other processes so
also ninja seems
this arcana protein is a housing is
machinery okay the housing is mine from
this one for others okay we have like a
ten argument genes for rice we have like
eight uh 18 and quite a lot and of
course elegant have eighteen for human
having four and four plus four okay i
mean other related
from here i want to show one engine
for this
police ackman protein you can find this
pattern
if
this micro name or someone is very sure
only 21 will have so this kind of
smarter will load this class of argument
this protein will move from cytoplasm to
perform
post transgression gene silence
okay another that if this one is very
long kind of when you like talking about
the three nuclei more they can load in
this class the protein that was a
nuclear to perform concretion silence
electricity in sciences protocol
epigenetic sciences so that means which
means either size of someone like
madness okay inside the function another
important thing only point out is that
even
they like
that one
that would buy them that could be you
could be safely
okay but of course the new type also
determine which argument they go for
instance if i go on predominantly
associated with you okay so you become
the super killer show pretty much all
the armies as well as coming mandarin
but if first new kind of
looking through arc number five it's
part of mainly involving the control
gene line which would come from the
flowering and the
flowering feedback
or
in the other foreign two which you can
choose microbial uh controls the
bacteria compressor uh virus so which
means okay from the home message from
this slice
soma rna size is important and the first
nucleotide is also critical for the
function
but how the definitive size is
characterized collaborative nuclei does
mean we must have a precisely micro
production
which occurring from molecular level
because sine processing is critical and
really critical
early stage when i was studying in texas
and we began to study once special
reporting
here we find that i have a special
partner called micro166175
turned out this
but
from here we find where the industries
okay we want to start building more
police in my planning on safety
but it turned out in our properties
level nine those nine g make same micron
eventually have the same product so but
let's precursor g the sub
now what primary
substring of the micron would go the
is different you can see we typically
will see micrometer microphones here but
important part that we could have low
basis there
is that in torque have offstand
okay so typically even final propane the
same but this terminal group different
and the base line difference really
becoming different
loci for for these micron genes
we are holding our work to study the
function of ionosign of a micro name 166
requiring this kind of pattern
which is you make a constitutional
expression of all of mine if i turn on
the phenotype is quite different sun
because it's really severe some of them
really don't have anything that they
have
we curious what happens so we just you
know check the microwave
we find that by this pattern if it's a
primary subject of micronutrient
primarily
here then you barely produce any
migraine it turns out then do not have a
severe hemorrhagic mind big time
so take home message for this slide is
that is even final product the same
however in substrate structure is really
critical structure methods they will get
determined whether or not migraine
individually perception
what happens across the station we just
summarize the principles so
we know
people have been previously published
many you know
used by informaticas they find this
pattern which publishes several people
are the names of weaver snap
and they find technically by microname
from this kind of structure that should
have linear structure that station that
might buy so the sensor in single strand
outstanding jungle region they conquered
it here the 15 or something nuclei they
can cut produce certain intermediate
products from the green microwave so
this pre-microrna this primer here will
be fully processed making micron day
that's what it will be written in vision
we call them user organic processing
however
once your primary they formed rather
communicated with special alternative
random group
these look for the sensor by dyson
they're also constantly in the superstar
and after jungle region they can reverse
process okay so we're going to account
for here cardiff into six new
so finally they cannot make function of
micronutrients so
so in other words that when primary
structure is complicated okay they have
multiple processing methods they can be
by normal possession make this
micronutrient but also they can be
destroyed by our normal processor
so we get the kingdom from here we see
that you know this structure that may
serve as a second level another level of
genetic emission eugenic religion must
be sensitive by enabled by vibrant
nuclear protein complex so this one
treated our wonderful directional
research with the biology
biology height in the second structure
being well we find when we're starting
the micronutrient cell processing we
realize once a fundamental difference
between human and the plants
so for instance for humans we know prime
minister was a museum for certified or
covered protein workers russia and india
russia was censored
region containing level type then
produce
pre-micron name
length called cytoplasms called another
complex hypercomplex blood processing
but the plants is quite different
we know this disarm equivalent to
georgia we know how one protein kind of
melody is equivalent to ddsa but in
human they do not have a cerebral
product but plants
have a similar community because many
many years ago you know you can see in
2005 people having to find in wide
opposition
where this migrant will
fully process the substrate of the
little but substitute final product
but in sewer mutant the primary pendulum
is probably accumulated but they do not
lose any migraine
so this strong genetic evidence
indicating syria might be very critical
very critical to processing of migrants
so this will begin with a chapter for
the invisible this protein
so next we're going to you know
to see what exactly was still the
function for enable for
for the animal intelligence turns out
we do quick adjustation as a refining
protein whatever the weight itself is
left 100 kilograms however if range of
retention we find this protein size
around 700 kilograms which means this
protein must partner with many other
protein formed viable nuclear binder
protein complex microcomplex
actually if we improve bioinformatic
competition you'll find a cerebral
protein they form this kind of
this interesting disorder body they
started neutral part have golden era
this folded area previously had been
sorted by former slaughter look at the
heart
working
like structure my importance is that in
the entrepreneurial part and some
neuropathy terminal they can form this
other region each disorder region they
have several meanings first of all that
means this protein through protein and
recycling partner with anabolic
meanwhile this is a disorder protein the
typically they form structure compounded
other protein but this kind of binding
is
now the pilot ability illustration that
can reach the partners for different
functions that which suggests this
really protein they may have many
different functions many many partners
okay so we use bicameral approach to
serial transaction line to decode
through the vital partners which were
found here okay so this was the
progressives in my lab so we're pure by
the pseudo-particularly complex
whatever
around the cpr1 cbp in the program this
podium
previously people use genetic approach
or body code we know and establish the
partner of this civil uh protein
but not passing
another cell protein which you see in
the grains in alcoholic yeah even
recover more peptides in its compounds
but
they
the function for this relationship being
silver is unknown okay so today we're
mainly focus this class of new partners
absolutely to study how exactly play
with super protein to perform biological
function
so first of all first of all we're going
to say this about swiss complex where
you just please protein because this
protein have been known is a rewarding
practice the working transcription
typically promotes inflammation and
removing the histone nucleosome for some
kind of islam virus replacement for a
nucleation nucleus and injection with
sarah so they will utilize into hybrids
okay so when water can
promote transfection but now we know
these three proteins interact with
cereal okay but spirit is the major play
in our metabolisms what can be used for
some hypothesis is that seriously
processing or
feedback or what will suit singapore
will come to attendance we can form many
times hypothesis for easily for our
testing is that we want to check this
mutant how this migrant
migrant level is so you can see
these columbia plants silver mutant have
upward civilian
that is foreign obviously attending a
molecular level you can see of what
serious mutant we can say much level
reducer expression by the sigil of dwarf
mutant they always say constantly and
what we call history significant micro
level combative columbia glance which
means it means your mutant background is
microphonically increased if to generate
the sequence you can find the canonical
micron with dependencies around one
choice micron will increase
we want to know whether or not this my
equipment rebuilds in such a mutant
because translation levels will be used
or because suppose the transcription of
events
so we do that this is very important
line so we just you know micron working
nine for several micron a because we
know this migraine will be increased in
signature could be the program we're
using gas line with transport procedures
so after every consultation
it turned out if from gas station level
your balance in the difference even
while type in the background this is the
background
but if you do poor you know for all
these
uh f2 population to race into you can
find this pattern you see
in y type sejaku and more
gas line which is the hotline but in
newton homozygous have leveled into
little diagonal expression which means
forward this mutant background beautiful
the g micron g transcription is reduced
okay that's very important because in
newton's background
micronic transcription the gene
transcription level was reduced
however
final product final product might be
result will increase okay so this
difference indicating indicating
that must have function you post the
transition level in other words
impossible
must
like or likely inhibit the micron
processing so to test the hypothesis we
have the many kind of process we ended
up here we cured by oxygen
protein from we call it
bacterial viruses
we can still do individual conditions so
we mix
suggest the drug protein with this my
rna and also with the control protein
you can find this pattern a normal
situation again in normal reconstitution
disorder that can process
rate isotope labor precursors labor well
to produce a conductor here but when you
provide surgical food protein you can
see the product the dramatically reduced
however substrate was increasing because
it cannot process after many many
repeats you can see this
so in other words these provide direct
evidence to show seijaku this list of
complex they can be keeping primary
processing so the question is that what
happens in labor so we began to check
because this is adp it's it is a
condensed cataclysm the word hypothesis
that may have happened function so just
especially in that field in the past 20
years people always believe this
situation of contact they can remove the
protein extreme protein from dna complex
while they said would not have had its
function however we didn't show here
where many different atoms implicated
intelligence function for this rna of
micronutrition so we began to release
this experiment so whichever medium is
lung will make a leaked primary name
okay third one is very absolutely
labeled the meeting with a long sub long
part of the time argument
we mix this one with charcoal protein
the common protein you see one mixed
structure two protein you can see this
this is full length for one native job
in the job
after mixed with that
maturity sure the version will be
released
it does have helix activity not only our
wounded dna also risk is rna so we do it
in extensive i cannot work we show
different bypass and use a mutant
immunization is that adp is an havoc
motif you can see this helical activity
with
compromise
so
i'll tell you that what will it
after it's had it is so important what
happens with being labeled we'll begin
to think about whether or not there is a
swin slope complex it can change
unstructured in labor so now we use one
type of knowledge called the bms okay
one chemical these chemicals very
special they can be active they can
react and perform the action with
unparalleled
angelini and symmetry on pattern amc
once mesolithic once by sleeping using
an army cannot be paired with like a new
energy in other words this one as long
as the supersonic part that we mess
lately
okay but double strand they do not have
this chemical reaction so it'll be fine
so based on this idea so we treat the
plants with ems okay when they bonus and
they are paired with a and the c
then we start you protect the rna we
perform food cutting system
why is regular reversal
if regular in that solution lastly you
provide regular rt you provide primer
like a primal extension once the meat
which is nicely aimed at the same
they're gonna fall off because they
cannot practice through this material
so you don't run a job you can see
others from even worse and now we use
another special label and purpose
translation the rivers and creepers
these special reverse computers they can
bypass each massive a and c however they
can eventually generate new vision in
other words even with simultaneous
insight is the signature of a
simultaneous okay we use this one as a
reflection of synthetic if you do not
have any nutrition
so use this idea very quickly you know
by chemical stuff we know this is
primary structure okay
i have a circuit here so we can a medium
primordial the primary extension so
without gear medicine
without any label of anc so no matrix y
capacitor or so that will know the
diagram you can see primary extension
always go back to the full length from
here to the outer end
however when german sediment you begin
to mess later on
you see in white devastation you can fit
many many times here okay and by the
mute
mutant background which do not have a
helix function can not want rna they can
pretty much the pattern have less this
kind of balls this will flatten this one
more than you can pretty much see these
things here
this cutter column obliques is migraine
gluten sleeping you see having many many
that root rich in normal condition
however
why we
example you see here so
you see columbia is doing blue line
that's the japanese background you can
see is you know with the dns meditation
okay the platform is match up laser cl a
so you can find this pattern many of
them have a significance okay so what we
mean by this kind of difference then you
use on a folding website you can find it
on a patent it's a binomial solution
vitamin solution you can see you see
they can form the permanent branching
group remember coming to the brain group
you can hear the
trigger of body processing for reduced
micron production
however institution background usually
now trouble because the media points
these linear points that promote
partnering production so you have more
amount
so this have been puffed into that a few
years ago so we conclusion for here so
series of complex they have two
functions kinetically they can promote
transcription okay control nuclear
nucleus of the modern but meanwhile
meanwhile this can be higher by silver
once they can then remove rna from
silver
with folding
weapons around this primary knee to work
making unsuitable
substrate for diesel complex processes
the blood processing in other words we
know that this semester of compass has a
good function why promote a normal
egyptian find the migrant product
depends on these can cook and foods
okay so this is one of the story
previously published
now we continue to work with many other
components we will not go to detail for
them but here so we know we mainly
previous slides we'll talk about the
microassessing but also work from my lab
and also are that shall we show that in
syrian involvement which immobilizing
which lighting also involves impacting
the border and also involving them some
their history has been calibrated the
control championship will not go detail
police that part however from here one
important hindu quest which began
cinching
why that secret okay by the way
civilization
okay
so we've began to think why is you know
these these proteins so have so many
functions now for your label that must
in some way the kind of control their
mind controls homostasis so once
especially for this interesting is all
the protein so we spent time in the past
few years to think i could investigate
how serial protein sensitivity was
likely to be labor
in our proteomics
one component is called the pag-1 it's a
chinese-s holdings on power subunits
okay we
know we recovered with polynomials we
confirmed we do you know single ip or
coexpression circuit and alternate
target protein okay immediately we can
easily
they
confirmed ph one and a certain problem
and when your provider's rnas is your
interaction remain the same which means
this kind of actually is a physical
induction other so individual solar rna
linkage
so
of course the other component is to
hybrid of the human macro intake domain
by a certain region but the question is
that what exactly is what we mean what
is a new interaction new pattern we know
for eucalyptus majority protein would be
graded for proteosome dependent revision
acid
however
for protein degradation have two
passwords one is a kind of six potential
another one is chinese
so what mean by that we know typically
any single polysome that contains all
subunits
units
these subunits mainly involve the
hepatite hydrogens
but if we perform the protein they have
involved in other processes we call the
nanny as regulatory subunits is
regulated so the subunits involve many
components they can censor your building
they can
well established for instance for
well-established welfare protein while
for the protein they can go unusually
their communication eventually go
through regulatory finally hydrolyzed or
called nucleus
however for many many proteins respect
for intensity of other problems like
that people sleep behind one
human stressor they can because they
have a large amount of
intrinsic water region so they can go
grab them through time as bonus on
we want to see what happens for our
cereal protein so we know for your vapor
solution okay if you treat us as perhaps
might of course
you will kill ms
which means it's probably not glass or
degraded canvas opponent from pathway
however if you're treated one special
chemical pyr what you want these ponies
to keep them they slap slightly if you
inhibit the activity of chinese six s
and six plus chromosomes by another
chinese solution last nation if you
treated chemicals you see this podium it
can be degraded
even out of food which means which means
this building they can bypass nankin as
regular subunits they have
they can
they could be translated to have their
own country as
began to purify this chinese chromosome
so maybe transgenic line we pure virus
complex in 800 minimum sodium
alright and also without adp so after 40
days you can see many different media
which is chinese audience and after this
one because the most popular
materials
because everybody want to use them so
now come back we purify the chinese
potency but mixed silver protein you can
say well in nature then quickly
by the treated and it's on the roof it
is stabilized okay by the control
program control iot on here they cannot
stabilize
they're not degrading it so what it
means provide the right evidence when
they're trying to as a bonus that can
degrade the symbol for you for
individual
so now come back here so we know this
ibp is translated with all the proteins
they can be directly attached like a one
called anious production production
but now we'll move people forward what
kind of similarly what consuming
triggers
they come back at another
okay
of course we're using
several independent methods okay these
were done by two another residents so we
use the signature civilian recipes is to
highlight the vibe in the cellar that we
do multiple independent approach we know
the interaction very well and
now
we want to see
whether or not this kindness really was
written
so a pure buddhist protein and is a
commercial stain
you can see these protein kindness okay
of course i can sell frustration
everything yeah but the value is a mixed
cereal protein like a cereal
that can be persevered
but how long we as a control which is a
partner on the
those in microprocessor unless they
cannot be frustrated okay so usually in
nature it means these kindness their
past was regular
use a civil subject
in labor labour which in english are not
gone mutants
so you can see compared to white type is
that protein cell proteins began
migrating faster which means this cereal
protein was a high performance
importance in that one have less
population they
meanwhile you can say another pattern if
sks page or this is a possible package
this one is ssh you can say this story
will be reported
suggesting you actually use the reason
for us legalize their civil devotion
that's people mentioned foreign so now
working around the force for autonomics
to identify individual residues that can
be persuaded it turned out we found this
pattern for in which acid we recover
this job we run the first four
proteomics we find 17 vegetables okay or
sodium that can be preservative
meanwhile we mild the product a little
bit
okay so we're combined together we'll
find
three clusters one cluster here these
guys get discussed here they can be so
where we main focus our research
we want to study one after the
presentation how to change similar
functions
so
illustration we cannot class leads one
together make it quick and beautiful one
is a high perforation
okay
so
phenotype like here okay so columbia
here silver mutant and
fully complementation like vascular
everywhere and this is the kind of
mutant like the quality
if we mutation
you know here in part change the
alignment
those can rescue
first conversation which means this 76
really doesn't matter not important
function
however if you change it now invitation
or
changes for rescue to atlanta and change
the a they can rescue everywhere but if
you change the d didn't you they either
have a residual similar thing that all
particles can scatter it's more
okay same similar pattern we've been
saying here if you change the three
eight that's your level well by changing
between three d it cannot make it part
because very small but they do not seem
stupid
so take home message is that
hyper motivation bonus is a function
and first for me for high qualitation is
not
enough
you know life but it's been that we can
detect this kind of pattern if you
change the a you can easily you have a
change of b
with the amount much less okay well
reduced which means hypopreservation was
stabilized reporting but of course for
me for destabilizing this protein same
thing if you check the micron went out
you can see
columbia here the mutant here okay
the
still rhythm but you change the change
to a in a they can rescue the y type
actually b they cannot okay this one is
also better than any better than b
so now
what do they do for your label level why
you know
problem between the functional and the
important meaning of them
then we have many hypotheses okay and we
could be under binding energy and
everything else we grew out turned out
we find this issue we do you know used
to hybrid okay you do in a way this is a
three thing building a 3d mutant way who
is to hybrid with someone we find this
resolution in white and silver they can
import them out and the color can go
everywhere but they change the a they
also go very well but actually
we do not say too much quality
okay same thing for here you can change
the 4a that grow
colony but actually 4d it cannot
occasionally
grow quality which means
there's no colon induction that
reinforces
the polypropylene with gum okay it's not
protein all the protein at least how
long and the serious music
they do not reaction okay so we
interpret because of basketball we can't
detect a and b okay so we're trying to
try and interpret because the hybrid
population simply varies the impact of
how one more stronger than the first
formula to make that function you want
to not be impacting how much stronger
then it will be unstable
so
of course we want to do this how it
labor works okay so we know uh colombia
again of the eucharistic hexamine
and columbia degree but in carbon newton
illustration will have a regular
preservation the protein might stabilize
if we put in nature of purify to refine
this honey as odinson and fit with the
recombinant protein with a newton and
this one quite stable but quenching the
hypo high voice for meaning force that
we must reduce okay same pattern we can
see here
so now
we bring all these together we know
yeah
unfortunate protein once they can be
recognized sensitive by for the region
kindness they can put a perturbation
marker here trigger protein sample this
is the potential vibration for the
vision
so
pretty much where he got fuel protein
component
now come back to our lips so pretty much
feeding this one last and probably
okay nice feels like very popular
stronger but the plant wouldn't have
been right so what exactly for this is
protein the green or grass especially
this protein is also invariably like
more than one thousand zero hundred and
acid but it will grow off of is so
insulated this other protein so we don't
know exactly a function for the label so
we're gonna focus that's like the focus
for the function you know what the bad
reflective protein function we name this
one for the subcontinent because
assuming our
so
we can begin to you know
we call either dungeon sir for protein
phosphorous or cell phone okay some
protein they have two formula formula
again we use the critical case line to
not call single mutant not called
another side one
gene workout uh as cell two genes you've
seen the building that daddy all have
really shot up in that sort of thing
foreign
in the northern silicons and we like
this thing that very much because
compared to colombia even plans for very
short stature i'm turning on but it
seems no change so if i think we think
people like agriculture like a rice
nonsense they can maintain productivity
with a result growing too much mass may
be good things for
improve our recovery trade so we spend a
quite long time to study like this
mutant
so
because our first approach we want to
study what are the micron involved here
we you know we'll do our general white
surrounding siblings okay through our
siblings so around the 300 well 700 uh
ipad 8 will find 107.
somehow knew them for the english
student government
although it will also find something for
the people you differentiated advanced
the newly born migrant
is kind of a civil independent okay but
most
for many silver dependent micron was
increased we can use this sequence
result also looking to you know on the
block you can use it to have you know
this kinetic microphone
here issue increase compatible olympia
government so at this moment we know the
ceremony
is the inhibited inhibitor of
microprocessing like microsoft because
the mutants don't have more micronic
okay so now what why type the humidity
of microprocessing so of course we check
that translation will protect other
presence of the trigger iron and see who
will bring short passages is a this is a
poster transformationally they can be
keeping the microphone
our question why why didn't do that so
we tested several hypotheses but later
on we ended this station we find we
generate mutant we detect several
proteins the mainly the key component in
micron password is argument protein
silicon protein we find a gram poly for
the nucleus a lot
but when you check on a level where no
rna will increase okay so that's likely
increase likely because you knew that
background have so many micronutrients
they're in the house to stabilize animal
protein okay a cereal pudding with
liquids here let's surprise us then
we'll do fully different ways and you'll
find
in this you can argue the background
okay company
remember we know
hybrid that's position was stabilized
and similar project that's why we're
taking that you know
frustration
even promote the possibility would like
to achieve the revolution okay because
we're no privilege like we know grp 4k
again was religion protein they treated
that mission
so
we just did that now we began doing
mutual for
kindness reconstitution
or truncated protein which do not impact
it with the sewing we can say you can
see it in pattern okay so
when you fit into this control protein
we see it you know by default
persuasions here
however when you're fitted with a full
and safe building they can promote
the population
meanwhile meanwhile they can promote the
prp that they also promote civil cell
proof protein population as well because
by default condition level rescue and
basic vibration of the substrate somehow
when this proportion certain protein and
silver protein merge together put
together somehow they promote the
possibilities for both protein okay so
bottom one is a commercial thing instead
of autoloading so called the
interpreter's data we conduct and
alphabet
to produce structure so this is a civil
you know level core structure that is
not religion is a set of one protocol
program or having this country's mother
body racist after body we do you know
hydrogen bomb induction or in the
hydrophobic condition
we somehow observed
so when needed together the syrup is all
the region because of the organ
okay so with the fact is the
reconstitution of a cerebral can make
this whole vessel make a better position
for kindness particulation that's what
hypothesis okay
so
for well since we did this once again
according to the
statement we also checked
other features well i know this is
this great idea so we said well what
i've done is told him they have another
function so again we're currently
we're missing with our name okay
seamless plan
primarily we find if
manipulate that machine
let's meet the background
if we calculate the kde they can save
this can you can reach to
uh
they can reach to
one more which is very high by the
infinity
protein and very strong and also we have
actually the helicase is like around you
know one
so
based on this slice which will form this
protein have much stronger final things
in one
which way forward implies before we make
hydrogen on a considerable protein we do
this example we mix serial protein with
receptacle produce wi-fi protein or
fullness interaction with syringe and
also mix with a truncated cell food
protein they do not interaction with the
serum we find after the mix
all the band similar by an army we shift
the problem which is the
exact protein is complex here but it's
not
[Music]
so if they can suppress the rna
considerably next step we would like the
lightweight inhibition micro processor
and kidney so we test this one we should
here so when mix is a
set
protein and newton forms
then we add a single protein intuition
that microprocessor you can see this
kind of pattern you know
sub-bond protein full length you set one
transition okay that do not impact
and same thing
so you will have full answer protein
looking inhibition
substitute processing take because less
and less okay
and by the truncation the value of that
okay same synthetic after many times
repeat
this
so
now we begin here this engages we want
to see me in the even example especially
for these two intrinsically
we want to study well i'm going to
change the nucleus to separation of each
other so we know by normal conditions
made it from motor vehicle service grp
they can certain protein and mainly
homogeneous particulation again is
faster in ukraine but from time to time
immersively will support
okay but if your check is a carbon
protein which shows typically mobile
condition so the body
that sparkers are your mutants inside
one circle
somehow somehow
in severed wide capacitor body was a
decrease okay in body
formation
now if you do the red acid bracket acid
you can bleach a single protein you can
quickly see the protein can recover okay
same simple but in both mute and wipeout
situation they have a similar pattern so
we're trying to incorporate that instead
of one side who they may change
intensity of cerebral palsy and out of
schedule combination but somehow they
can affect
parallel center keyboard
dynamics
but what a reverse region what what
happens what happens in cellular
subroutine in civil limit
we know in white conversation in the
stretch instead of one circle they can
pull many smarter
nucleus matters but still remove the
background you can see the human genius
okay
and how long
they
the
difference
this about us some very much like
indians
now these are native transgenic plants
if you do prototypes the program will
increase the protein level for both
subcoding and cerebral protein you can
see if you get the photographs
columbia protein they can form very
strong sparkles
pure bodies but if you're still a mutant
okay simultaneous
and if you
build them we do not say okay slash
liberal foundation simply they cannot
say that or just amazing progress but
you will survive full length several
proteins because these sparklers come
back so take your home medicine from
this life yourself set alongside the
protein they make content content in the
serial protein they perform
the regulator similar to functions so
let's bring together
we know
one on you know in the last uh
message but slice it down
when primary were transcribed by the
binding by civil protein either they can
recruiting subcode in their body at that
point they can hijack this primary
grenade from civic go back to the
subconscious of the broadcasting
processing meanwhile they can trigger
the civil persuasion maybe it is
unstable and the ghosts of the chinese
politicians maybe it's degrading
post already bringing all this together
what they say is primarily a possession
please have two levels to
inhibition why the chinese structure
structure another one of the physical
separation primary and the treatment
the police two levels of inhibition so
similar function will kind of become
true
okay so we consider literal civilian
centered is hard
interacting with many many proteins
production here we're going to talk
about
the
other processes to also involve the
concretion and artisans which was that
was your development
so
so far we you know
a long time talking about the story of
mainly
myopia uh by jenna is the one production
like that we have several years and
assuming last year we just became one
student the graduate and they working we
have several people what was the virus
project we didn't have time to about
here and uh
the narration and also from their
council funding
without further today and now i'm very
happy to take the question
because of time where you retain maximum
two questions
yeah
thank you
so i i
thought the x-ray connection
was inspected earlier on in the top
one component is x on sign two right you
said i'm two right
so
hexane is the axon okay equation on the
equation that's in rna the other
deviation the average of prime migration
okay so the conclusion for you lightly
and when i'm not involved
i would think that
for sure for sure they're going to
control stability of a primary kind
but my best factor and they can also
involve the massive messenger stability
okay that's likely
people already have reason going to
check
thanks
so i'm not sure i follow everything but
you mentioned the uh
form of syria yes uh
malfunctional and quickly degrading yeah
do you think it's
here it also forms like uh those
droplets this is office i think whether
it's because the transformative form
phosphorylated one could not form those
uh separation and maybe like
congratulations
okay that's exceptionally
that means that we know people many
people are fueled believe certainly they
can form the nuclear phase separation
whether or not what's reaching itself
the regulation that the liquid lps
then
be here tomorrow then come just you know
but i'm not going to stable or not the
answer is that we are doing that we'll
probably pick your ass maybe yes or just
pass it but then it's great advice we
continue uh you are the question you
know the strengths strength you know and
the design could continue to work
thank you for mr report
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu